we're parting in the middle and then
we'll cut some of the length off
it's important to make sure the customer
knows what's happening
but he can barely hear his customers
his hearing aids don't help much amid
the noise of the salon so he's dependent
on lip reading
that works best when he's only talking
to one person
we have a meeting where there are 15 or
20 people and everyone talks and makes
comments
i need an interpreter
and that's where verba voice comes in
the munich-based firm specializes in
sign language interpreting and speech to
text reporting
one hour of interpreting costs between
40 and 110 euros
customers range from germany's state
parliaments that want all citizens to be
able to follow the debates
to companies which employ hearing
impaired people
and interpreters don't even have to
leave the office it all happens online
they just log into an app and can then
act as go-betweens for hearing impaired
people and people who can hear
this information we have to improve our
flyer with all the information about
verbavoice
what's still missing
what do you think should be on it
online the interpreter translates the
questions and transmits the answers
okay
the idea is to improve hearing impaired
people's chances on the job market by
ensuring better communication and fewer
misunderstandings
the company sees itself as a pioneer
seven of its 34 employees are hearing
impaired those who can hear take a
weekly class in sign language
this means meeting
those who can't hear well used to have a
tough time finding jobs
i would say it's difficult
after my studies i applied for a job and
although i got interviews they always
asked me about phoning and communicating
i got one rejection after the next
but here i was taken immediately because
they were looking to employ deaf people
i found the right place to work and now
i can do the job i trained to do
and the company is very successful last
year it made a profit of 1.2 million
euros mostly with speech-to-text
reporting
profits are expected to double in the
coming year because of new regulations
to ensure accessibility to people with
disabilities
yes new laws
and the u.n convention on the rights of
persons with disabilities which requires
more and more hearing impaired children
will be able to go to standard schools
they'll be needing interpreters
when christopher needs an interpreter
it's his company that pays
already certified as a master hair
stylist he's hoping to open his own
salon in just a few years
cutting hair is my passion i grew up
with it i really enjoy it
and nobody cuts my hair as well as he
does he feels it and how he blow dries
it makes a difference
when he was away doing his training to
become a master i had to go to another
hairdresser and that was okay but
kristoff is unique
christophe
is just one of tens of thousands in
germany who are hearing impaired
this represents a huge demand for sign
language interpreters helping their
chances on the job market